the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right so let's see so first we have
L 1 is equal to bacon eggs I'm going to
short for them sure hand this L 2 is
equal to toast and jam brunch I should
actually make these arrows brunch is
equal to L 1 so this is just a liasing
which means brunch is going to point to
whatever L 1 object points to and if I
do L 1 dot append juice L 1 is now going
to be bacon eggs and juice okay this L 1
has been mutated to be that and since
brunch still points to the same object
that L 1 points to brunch is now going
to point to there okay so when I do
brunch dot extend L 2 I'm going to take
whatever brunch is which is this part
here and I'm going to extend it by L 2
which is toast and jam okay so it's just
going to take a large list of those five
elements because because of this side
effect issue where brunch was it was
this pointing to the same thing that L 1
was pointing it to okay
so it's close but I think perfect yes
that's that's the right answer